le 16 mars au palais de l'elysée le ton
est solennel
la rhétorique martial nous sommes en
guerre toute l'action du gouvernement et
du parlement doit être désormais tournés
vers le combat contre l'épidémie
le pays est en guerre les françaises
sont appelés à rester chez eux
pourtant la veille du discours
présidentiel le gouvernement décide du
maintien du premier tour des élections
municipales le chef de l'état affirme
que les différentes familles politiques
ont été consultés sur le sujet
la décision est soutenu par le chef du
gouvernement notre décision a été fondée
sur des motifs scientifiques et elle est
parfaitement assumé sur ces motifs
scientifiques et c'est peut-être là le
premier couac dans la gestion de cette
crise par l'exécutif le maintien des
élections alors que l'épidémie commence
à sévir en france le sujet fait débat
l'opposition monte au créneau et dénonce
une décision unilatérale
je répète que jamais le rassemblement
national n'a été consulté par le
gouvernement sur le report du premier
tour des municipales
ce mensonge répété cent fois est
vraiment suspect non edouard philippe
vous ne nous avait rien demandé
concernant le premier tour des
municipales
ne fuyez pas vos responsabilités mais le
vrai caillou dans la chaussure du
gouvernement durant cette crise
c'est sans doute la question des masques
à l'heure où de nombreux pays à travers
le monde distribuer gratuitement des
masques de protection alors population
la france connaît une situation de
pénurie colère chez ceux qui sont en
première ligne notamment parmi les
soignants et les forces de l'ordre
aujourd'hui les soignants que moi je le
présente le seul problème que nous avons
c'est qu'ils sont toujours dans la même
situation qu'au départ sans rien sans
masque sans protection sans test il ya
un décalage entre les discours du
président de la république et les actes
sur le terrain pour le moment les
mesures pour nous protéger ne sont
toujours pas là et protéger la
population ce que nous sommes en contact
de différentes personnes au cours de la
journée dont nous sommes aussi des
vecteurs potentiels donc c'est très
compliqué de travailler dans des
conditions pareilles
car la france a besoin de policiers mais
deux policiers qui sont valides et qui
sont capables de faire leur travail au
cours des derniers mois les
préconisations du goût
moment sur le port du masque ont été
pour le moins contradictoire d'abord
jugé inutile le port du masque est
ensuite recommandé et sera finalement
obligatoire dès demain dans les
transports en commun sous peine d'amendé
aujourd'hui il n'y a aucune indication
acheter des masques pour la population
française les masses n'ont aucun intérêt
pour le grand public le port du masque
en population générale dans la rue ça ne
sert à rien je refuse de recommander le
port du masque pour tous et jamais le
gouvernement ne l'a fait notre objectif
est que chaque français puisse avoir
accès à un masque soit par la
distribution commerciale qui peut
exister aujourd'hui elles y sont très
attentifs soit par les collectivités
locales qui sont engagés soit par l'état
les transports sont un des cas où le
port du masque pourra être obligatoire à
compter du 11 mai de quoi s'y perdre
comme au sujet de la réouverture des
écoles annoncées par le chef de l'état
pour ce mardi
elle suscite de nombreuses inquiétudes
en france chez certains parents d'abord
qui redoutent que leurs enfants ne
revienne infectés
chez les mères ensuite qui craignent que
leur responsabilité soit engagée en cas
de nouvelles contaminations et chez les
enseignants enfin qui parlent de mesures
sanitaires inapplicable dans les classes
ce brassage non voulues lorsque les gens
se déplacent à plus de 100 km il aura
lieu au fait où sein des villes doué
sein de leurs écoles qui vont être de
vrais laboratoire de deux virus quoi
concrètement nous moi ce que je retiens
aussi c'est qu'on mette des cobayes
concrètement on va voir comment ça se
passe alors on remet les profs dans les
écoles on remet les personnels on
regarde ce que ça donne sur les enfants
les parents auraient pu réalisera après
mais c'est complètement irresponsable
pour les français ce lundi 11 mai
marquera le retour d'une certaine
liberté sacrifiés au nom de la lutte
contre le virus
pour l'exécutif en revanche une période
difficile pourrait commencer et celle
des contes et des explications sur une
gestion de crise très critiquée